PRESIDENT BIDEN, LOOK IN THE
MIRROR.
>> Sean: SENATOR GRAHAM, THANK
YOU.
>> NOW, LAST NIGHT WE HERD FROM
TWO GOLD STAR FEATHERS, LOST A
HERO MARINE SONS AT LAST WEEK'S
TERROR ATTACK AT CAR SIGH TERROR
ATTACK IN KABUL CAUSED BY JOE
BIDEN'S SELF-INFLICTED AFGAN
EXIT DISASTER, ALL PREVENTIBLE,
ALL OF THIS HUMAN SUFFERING, ALL
OF THIS VIOLENCE, THE NEEDLESS
LOSS OF LIFE ALL CAUSED BY
BIDEN, NOW WE KNOW HE KNEW, EVEN
AS HE TRIES TO BLAME EVERYBODY
ELSE EXCEPT HIMSELF.
HERE WITH REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOEY JONES AND
NEVADA SENATE CANDIDATE SAM
BROWN WHO BOTH SERVED AND WERE
WOUNDED IN AFGHANISTAN, ALONG
WITH GOLD STAR WIFE, JENNY
TAYLOR, HER HUSBAND, ARMY MAJOR,
BRENT TAYLOR, KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN IN 2018.
JOEY, LET ME START WITH YOU.
IN 2010, IED RELATED INCIDENT
RESULTED IN THE LOSS OF BOTH
YOUR LEGS ABOVE THE KNEE, SEVERE
DAMAGE TO YOUR RIGHT FOREARM,
BOTH WRISTS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL TODAY.
>> FIRST, SEAN, WILL ET ME SAY,
WHATEVER INJURIES I SUSTAINED
ARE NOTHING COMPARED TO THE PAIN
THE GOLD STAR FAMILY'S GOING
THROUGH.
I'VE SEEN IT FIRSTHAND, I
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED IT THANK GOD
AND MY HEART GOES OUT TO ALL OF
THEM, THE DOZENS I KNOW AND THE
13 THAT WERE JUST CREATED AND
EVERYONE THAT HAS LOST A HERO
OVERSEAS.
BUT WHAT BOTHERED ME SO MUCH IS,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S ALL THESE
EXCUSES THAT COME UP FROM JOE
BIDEN CHECKING HIS WATCH, MAYBE
HE'S LOOKING AT A ROSARY THAT
WAS HIS SON, MAYBE THIS, MAYBE
THAT.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAYBE.
IF YOU'RE THE FAMILY OF SOMEONE
WHO DIED JUST DAYS AGO IN AN
OPERATION THAT MUCH OF THE
COUNTRY THINKS WASN'T ON THE UP
AND UP, THE INTEL WASN'T CORRECT
OR THE PRESIDENT MADE BAD
DECISIONS, MAYBE AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
YOU NEED TO JUST BE THERE AND BE
IN THAT MOMENT AND BE THERE FOR
THEM.
AND IF IT MEANS THAT YOU'RE THE
VERBAL PUNCHING BAG TODAY,
THAT'S OKAY.
I MEAN, HECK, MAN, YOU JUST WENT
THROUGH SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
SHOULD GO THROUGH AND YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY THINGS AND HAVE
EMOTIONS THAT MAYBE DIFFERENT A
WEEK FROM NOW AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO I DON'T WANT TO USE THE
WORLDS OF GOLD STAR FAMILIES AND
SOME POLITICAL PUNCHING BAGS BUT
I JUST WISH JOE BIDEN HAD THE
WHEREWITHAL AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO BE THERE BE
IN THE MOMENT AND SHOW THEM THAT
RESPECT.
AND IF THEY SAY HE DIDN'T I'LL
TAKE THEIR WORD FOR IT AND JUST
SAY WE ALL DESERVE BETTER
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU SAM
BROWN, YOU GRADUATED FROM WEST
POINT, YOU GOT A GREAT
DISTINCTION, YOU BECAME AN
AIRBORNE RANGER SEPTEMBER, '08
YOU WERE STRUCK BY AN IED, IT
SEVERELY WOUNDED. YOU.
A THREE YEAR JOURNEY OF
REHABILITATION AND RECOVERY.
YOUR THOUGHTS TODAY?
DO YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS ABOUT
SERVING THE WAY THIS NOW HAS
ENDED?
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, I'VE GOT A
MESSAGE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST ME.
THIS IS AFTER TALKING TO MANY
OTHER VETERANS WHO SERVED THERE.
SOME OF MY OWN FAMILY MEMBERS.
I'M ONE OF THREE IN MY DIRECT
FAMILY WHO HAVE SERVED IN
AFGHANISTAN, AND THERE'S TWO
THEMES THAT ARE COMING OUT FROM
THIS.
ONE IS, MOST OF US DON'T REGRET
WHAT WE DID THERE, BECAUSE, AT
THE END OF THE DAY, WE WERE
CONFIDENT IN THE HELP AND THE
ASSISTANCE AND THE SECURITY THAT
WE PROVIDED FOR THE AFGANS THAT
WE HAD CARE OVER AT THAT TIME.
AND FOR WHATEVER PERIOD OF TIME
THAT THEY HAD SOME SHELTER AND
SECURITY FROM THE TALIBAN OR
OTHER THREATS, THAT WAS WORTH
SOMETHING, AND WE FELT GOOD
ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHAT WE DON'T APPRECIATE,
AND WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS ALMOST
SINGLE HANDEDLY, ALONG WITH THE
TOP BRASS LEADERSHIP OUT OF DOD,
HAS DONE, HAS CAUSED MANY OF US
TO FEEL THAT WE HAVE BEEN LIED
TO OVER THE YEARS ABOUT OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE AFGAN PEOPLE,
AND TO THE MISSION THERE.
AND HERE'S THE REALLY SAD THING,
AND HERE'S WHAT AMERICA NEEDS TO
KNOW IS, SEAN, I KNOW YOU KNOW
THIS, MANY OF THOSE WHO SERVE IN
UNIFORM COME FROM MULTI
GENERATIONAL FAMILIES.
HERE'S THE SECOND THING THAT
PEOPLE ARE TELLING ME TODAY.
WE'RE DONE.
JOE BIDEN HAS LOST THE TRUST AND
FAITH OF THOSE FAMILIES, MANY
FAMILIES WHO HAVE SERVED FOR
GENERATIONS, THAT WE WOULD RAISE
OUR RIGHT HAND AND BE AVAILABLE
AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF AND DO WHAT
OUR COUNTRY ASKED US TO DO.
AND PEOPLE ARE SAYING, WE'RE
DONE.
MY CHILDREN, MY GRANDCHILDREN,
WILL NOT BE A TOOL OF ELECTED
AND UNELECTED OFFICIALS, THEIR
PRIORITIES, THEIR FOREIGN POLICY
OBJECTIVES.
WE WILL NOT BE TOOLS FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S A SAD, SAD INDICTMENT
OF WHERE WE'RE AT IN AMERICA
WHEN YOU HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE
SAYING THAT.
AND SO WHAT I'M TELLING FOLKS IS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PUSH BACK AGAINST THESE
ELECTED OFFICIALS, AND THAT WE
DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY FROM OUR
TOP BRASS OUT OF DOD.
>> Sean: YEAH.
>> PEOPLE CAN HEAR MY FULL
STATEMENT ON JOE BIDEN ASKING
FOR HIS RESIGNATION ON MY WEB
SITE CAP SAM BROWN.COM AND JOIN
ME ON THIS MISSION OF BRINGING
BACK HONOR AND INTEGRITY TO OUR
ARMED SERVICES
>> Sean: JENNY TAYLOR, YOU'RE A
GOLD STAR WIFE, YOU HAVE SEVEN
CHILDREN, YOUR HUSBAND WAS
KILLED NOVEMBER 23RD, 2018, IN
AFGHANISTAN, HE SERVED WITH THE
UTAH NATIONAL GUARD.
YOU SAID, FOR THOSE THAT SAY WAS
IT WORTH IT, YOU SAID I DON'T
THINK THAT FOR A SECOND THAT IT
WAS A WASTE.
BUT YOU ALSO SAID THAT YOU'VE
TALKED TO MANY OTHER GOLD STAR
FAMILIES, AND IT FEELS LIKE
EVERY ONE OF US IS RELIVING
THIS.
SEVEN CHILDREN WILL NEVER SEE
THEIR DAD.
I CAN'T IMAGINE.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, I WAS
LISTENING TO EVERYTHING YOU'RE
SAYING SO FAR AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT 90% OF THE PEOPLE GETTING
EVACUATED OR WE SHOULD GO FOR A
HUNDRED PERCENT.
I HAVE ONE STATISTIC FOR YOU.
A HUNDRED PERCENT OF GOLD STAR
KIDS DON'T GET RAISED BY THAT
PARENT MISSING.
A HUNDRED PERCENT P OF GOLD STAR
MOMS WILL NEVER GET TO HUG THEIR
SON OR DAUGHTER AGAIN.
A HUNDRED PERCENT OF GOLD STAR
SPOUSES LIKE ME WILL SPEND THE
REST OF OUR LIVES WITHOUT OUR
SWEET HEART.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I WILL NOT
WONDER.
I WILL NEVER WONDER IF MY
HUSBAND DIED IN VAIN OR WHY HE
SERVED OR IF IT WAS WORTH IT.
I WILL NEVER LET MYSELF GET TO
THE POINT WHERE I THINK THAT WAS
A WASTE OR NEVER SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
DO I LIKE THE WAY THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED LATELY?
OF COURSE NOT.
NONE OF US APPROVE OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION.
BUT I WILL NEVER QUESTION WHY MY
HUSBAND SERVED.
WHY THE OTHER 2500 HAVE DIED IN
THIS WAR, AND THE THOUSANDS THAT
HAVE DIED FOR THE OTHER WARS,
THE OTHER CAUSES THROUGHOUT
AMERICA'S HISTORY.
WE DIE BECAUSE OF WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN.
WE BELIEVE IN THESE PRINCIPLES.
WE BELIEVE IN HOPE.
WE BELIEVE IN SPREADING HUMANITY
AND OPPORTUNITY AROUND THE
WORLD.
MY HUSBAND DIDN'T JUST DIE TO
PROTECT ME AND OUR SEVEN LITTLE
BABIES.
HE DIED BECAUSE HE BELIEVED THE
AFGAN PEOPLE ALSO DESERVED A
CHANCE.
THEY DESERVED HOPE AND
OPPORTUNITY, EDUCATION AND
FREEDOM.
AND I'LL TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT
I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
REALIZE.
I HOPE THIS REALLY SINKS IN.
MEN LIKE MY HUSBAND, AND THE 13
WHO WERE KILLED LAST WEEK AND
THE THOUSANDS THAT HAVE DIED IN
THIS 20-YEAR WAR ON TERRORISM,
THEY DIED TRYING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
THEY DIED TRYING TO MAKE IT
BETTER.
WORK.
AND THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR ALL
OF US NOW IS, ARE WE WILLING TO
LIVE WITH THAT SAME DEDICATION?
ARE WE WILLING TO LIVE IN A WAY
THAT MAKES IT WORTH IT TO THEM,
TO HONOR THE LIVES THAT THEY
HAVE GIVEN?
BECAUSE, AGAIN, A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF GOLD STAR FAMILIES
HAVE LOST AT LEAST 90% OF THAT
CHANCE.
THEY'VE LOST ALL OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH THAT
LOVED ONE AGAIN FOR THE REST OF
THEIR MORTAL LIVES.
THAT'S A REALLY HEAVY STATISTIC.
>> Sean: JENNY, SAM, AND JOEY,
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH WORDS.
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN THROUGH SO
MUCH.
VERY HARD FOR PEOPLE TO RELATE
TO.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
I KNOW I SPEAK FOR MYSELF, AND I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR THIS AUDIENCE.
I WANT TO THANK EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SERVICE AND SAD SACRIFICE AND
PAIN THAT YOU'VE ALL BEEN
THROUGH.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
YOU ARE WHAT -- YOU'RE THE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE AMERICA GREAT.
YOU'RE THE GREAT AMERICANS THAT
WE LOVE AND ADMIRE.
WE NEVER LEAVE AMERICANS BEHIND.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORIES WITH THE AUDIENCE